[Musique]
general electric symbole d'une
impuissance public bonjour à tous
bienvenue dans dimanche en politique
votre émission de débat en franche comté
quand une grande entreprise décident de
liquider un millier d'emplois que
peuvent faire nos pouvoirs publics
suffit-il de scander comme le fait
depuis le début de la semaine bruno le
maire le ministre de l'économie que ce
plan social n'est pas acceptable
nos élus ont-ils des marges de manoeuvre
une quelconque influence face à une
multinationale qui s'était engagé à
créer un millier d'emplois et qui quatre
ans plus tard ça soit sur ses promesses
et aille à vif dans ses effectifs à
belfort ces questions on va en débattre
et on va aller poser à nos quatre
invités je vous les présente tout de
suite denis sommer député la république
en marche du doubs également sur ce
plateau cédric perrin sénateurs les
républicains du territoire de belfort
bastien photo conseiller municipal et
départementales de belfort membres de la
gauche républicaine est socialiste et
patrice lombard conseiller régional du
rassemblement national bonjour à tous
les quatre merci d'avoir un jeu noté
notre invitation
alors vous en avez l'habitude cette
émission vous pouvez l'a commentée sur
les réseaux sociaux interpeller nos
invités avec le mot diez qui s'affiche
dit mme paul fc comme dimanche en
politique franche comté je me ferai au
cours de ce débat le relais de certaines
de vos questions
alors messieurs le mardi 28 et mais au
surlendemain des élections européennes
la direction de general electric a donc
officialisé un plan social d'envergure
plus de 1000 emplois supprimés
principalement à belfort six jours plus
tard lundi en début de semaine le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
s'est déplacé dans la cité du lion
rencontrer les représentants syndicaux
les élus locaux également les salariés
concernés par ces licenciements eux ne
croyait guère aux miracles politiques
écoutent ces quelques réactions
recueillies lundi jour de la visite du
ministre
ce que je peux apporter mais bon
je pense que la marge de manoeuvre assez
faibles on verra j'adore pas grand chose
quoi je pense c'est plus du trois dormir
je reste sceptique sur beaucoup de
choses à mon avis on nous enfume comme
tout le temps et j'attends la suite des
événements vous pensez que la politique
ne peut pas agir face à une
multinationale
j'y crois plus tu crois pas du tout
c'est lé souhaitait rentrer un maximum
d'argent pour les actionnaires
quant à presser le citron gars plus dur
est ce que vous pensez vraiment pas que
les politiques peuvent vous savez ils
font n'importe qui ça va opérer
[Musique]
voilà pour ces réactions de salariés de
general electric cédric perrin vous avez
rencontré le ministre lundi à belfort
est ce que comme ses salariés vous
doutez sûr que je doute mais si on a pas
d'espoir on n'avancera pas donc il était
important que le ministre vienne il a
été important qu'ils puissent être
qu'ils puissent entendre les syndicats
parce que je voudrais quand même le dire
très bon enfin publiquement les
syndicats ont une attitude extrêmement
responsable extrêmement intéressante
dans la politique de diversification
qu'ils entrevoient et puis surtout le
ministre a complètement changé de fusil
d'épaulé concernant le discours qu'il
nous fallait puisque une réponse à une
question au gouvernement que je lui ai
fait il ya quelques semaines il
m'expliquait il expliqué qu'il n'y avait
pas d'avenir pour le gaz
sinon quoi je me suis évidemment inscrit
en faux et lundi lors de la réunion il a
expliqué linverse c'est-à-dire qu'elle
considère qu'il ya un avenir pour le gaz
et donc je pense que c'est déjà une
avancée très importante qui consiste à
dire qu'il ya un avenir pour le gaz et
un avenir pour belfort et qui a des
compétences
une expérience à des comptes et des
compétences d expérience et un
savoir-faire à belfort qu'il faut
impérativement maintenir d'où l'intérêt
de travailler sur la diversification
quelle marge de manoeuvre en les élus
écoutez les marges de manoeuvre c'était
un groupe mondialement installé avec
effectivement des directions qui
aujourd'hui essentiellement américaines
mais il faut que nous trouvions en
termes de marges de manoeuvre des
solutions pour pouvoir ré employés les
talents réemploi les expériences et
gardé à belfort ces gens qui vont
pouvoir le moment venu quand le gaz aura
redémarré parce qu'il redémarrera et
bien pouvoir de travailler
comment à l'indépendance l'indépendance
énergétique de la france et je pense que
c'est un sujet majeur et donc la
diversification la possibilité de
réemployer les gens sur place c'est
quelque chose de très important on a
juste un problème de temporalité
puisqu'aujourd'hui on a une partie des
salariés qui évidemment va perdre son
emploi et qui nécessite évidemment qu'on
travaille dans l'immédiateté et d'un
autre côté une nécessité de travailler
sur une diversification du tissu
industriel qui nécessite de prendre du
temps on parlera sans doute tout à
l'heure des diverses sujets qui peuvent
être quand même gagné mais ça prendra du
temps donc il ya ce problème de
temporalité qu'il faut aux rivages de
nice mais on l'a entendu les salariés
doutent il s'interroge sur le
comportement du gouvernement michel
naudy par exemple on peut se demander si
l'état n'est pas complice ça va jusque
là les réactions que l'on reçoit parce
que le timing interpelle ji a annoncé
son plan social deux jours après les
élections européennes
est ce que il ya une complicité du
gouvernement au moins sur le timing de
l'annoncé
je ne le crois pas pas une seule seconde
nous avons rencontré bruno le maire
quelque temps avant les quelques jours
en fait avant les élections européennes
et bruno le maire n'avait aucune
information sur le moment mais vous le
croyez mais bien sûr mais au nom de quoi
je ne crois pas regardez par exemple psa
annonce la fermeture des rib en cours en
plein mouvement des gilet jaune
est-ce que c'était à un moment opportun
depuis la direction du groupe
je peux vous assurer que ce genre de
considérations ils s'en moquent
totalement cédric rappelé que general
electric c'est un groupe américain
les dirigeants de general inscriptions
aux états unis et le dirigeant de nike
france est un ancien conseiller les
mathématiques mais c'est pas lui qui
décide de soltani lunel annonce c'est
sûr que non c'est pas lui qui décide en
réalité ce sont les américains qui
décident à quel moment ils prennent
leurs décisions et à quel moment ils là
il l'a publié
la question qui est posée aujourd'hui
moi je comprends l'attitude des salariés
il ya mille emplois qui vont être
supprimés on va pas leur demander d'être
d'être content donc qu'ils soient en
colère qu'il le dise et que quelques
paris doute je le comprends tout à fait
et j'ai été militant syndical j'étais
dans une entreprise je sais que c'est
compliqué ce genre de situation ceci dit
si on veut s'en sortir si on veut
construire des solutions il faut à la
fois que les salariés bien évidemment se
mobilisent parce que ça ne peut pas se
faire ce qu'ils font encore vendredi
matin a laissé la sortie d'une
tyrolienne et moi j'ai rencontré
régulièrement les organisations
syndicales pour travailler avec
notamment avec l pardon notamment sur
les questions de diversification il faut
que les politiques soient rassemblés
parce que à la direction de general
electric qui l'entendront qu'un seul
discours et ce discours est bien il faut
qu'il soit porté par l'ensemble des élus
s'empêche pas que sur un sujet ou un
autre nous puissions avoir des
désaccords mais face à general electric
l'unité elle doit être de rigueur
patrice lombard comment vous vous
qualifier l'attitude des pouvoirs
publics et du gouvernement
cette affaire avec la manière qu'on
vient d'entendre c'est assez c'est à
nantes dans la clairvoyance des des
employés qui sont les employés d'un haut
niveau et qui veulent garder évidemment
leur emploi et leur technicité mais on
se rend compte malheureusement que
qui voit très clair dans cette je suis
pas tout à fait d'accord l'annoncent
comme on disait monsieur sommaire ou
s'est tout d'un coup on s'aperçoit un
lundi matin a pas d'élection que la
filière gas gas marche pas d'abord c'est
pas le cas en plus c'est assez étonnant
que dès lundi matin on découvre ce genre
de choses c'est ça se découvre c'est
quelque chose qui se prévoit qui se sent
qu'ils se voient donc déjà l'information
est fausse
en plus le commandant on a bien vu que
les américains avaient voulu comment se
saisir de la petite perle que nous
avions chez nous et nous en avons
beaucoup pour récupérer les technologies
et ensuite essayer de faire du bénef
avec puisque notre comment notre façon
de voir les choses nettement différente
que celle du président américain qui lui
vous l'a dit très clairement c'est
america back again ou america first donc
nous nous sommes là derrière avec une
entreprise privée qui en a racheté une
autre avec des signatures qui ont été je
pense que l'avenir nous le dira un peu
plus clairement qu'ils ont été faites
avec des contraintes qui sont pour
l'instant il ya une provision qui a été
faite le
en cas de non emploi des noms dans
bausch des 1000 en bouche privé les 50
années
voilà qui était prévu de façon qui était
budgété sont réinvestis principalement à
belfort a priori c'est youri aux mille
ministres mais ça on n'en est pas sûr
donc pour moi l'annoncent déjà elle et
elle n'est pas vrai et le système de
prédation va porter un énorme tort
comment alstom et à la france puisque
nous vendons beaucoup de choses qui
marchent très bien chez nous et nous
n'avons pas la même façon de gérer
puisque c'est nous pensons plus au
niveau du 1 100 e national nous pensons
plus en état nation est en état stratège
à longue échéance puisque l'histoire été
lancé par monsieur macron de sio macron
qui fait des discours et qui connaît
bien les choses on l'a encore vu hier
pendant toute une journée il est capable
de citer beaucoup de choses
a priori si les aussi intelligent que ça
il aurait dû voir j-10 doit comprendre
que le plan social ne nous convient pas
qu'il peut et qu'il doit être améliorée
bastien photo est ce que bruno le maire
est convaincant quand il dit c'est pas
acceptable
vous comprenez bien ce chevreuil qu'on
est dans une situation dans laquelle
depuis maintenant 30 ans dans le pays
ont fait venir les responsables
politiques sur les plateaux de
télévision pour le demander de commenter
les drames qui ont une histoire
je veux souligner ici avant de parler
plus spécialement du dossier de general
electric qui nous préoccupe que la
désindustrialisation c'est pas une
catastrophe naturelle
elle est le produit d'une histoire
humaine de choix politiques qui ont été
ceux de l'abandon de la production de
l'économie de production dans d'autres
pays on n'aura pas le temps de
développer ces éléments là mais il est
fondamental pour donner droit à ce que
nous venons de voir à travers
l'expression du salarié ne devoir n'est
pas seulement d'avoir un langage de
commisération en regardant et en
considérant effectivement comme légitime
la colère qui la leur aujourd'hui il
faut au plus profond de nous mêmes la
comprendre et quand je dis la comprendre
ça veut dire y faire droit parce qu'au
fond on les a accoutumé depuis 30 ans à
ce que les responsables politiques je ne
m'exprime pas en termes partisans en
disant cela
ça a concerné tous les libéraux de ce
pays la gauche comme la droite qui se
sont succédé depuis 30 ans dans le pays
ils ont donné le sentiment que la
politique était devenu littéralement
impuissante face
je dirais aux effets de la
mondialisation financière et est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ça est ce que la
politique est impuissante ou es ce que
vous avez les uns les autres vous êtes
quatre élues sur le plateau les moyens
de faire sur ce dossier le geste
lorsqu'il existe des outils qu'il existe
des moyens à court à moyen et à long
terme et qu'elle on va on va y venir
dans le détail vous voulez d'abord le
sujet de suite à court terme la question
centrale là c'est celle de fournir une
solution à toutes celles et ceux qui
risquent demain de perdre leur emploi
ça veut dire leur classement la
mobilisation un plan marshall pour en
fait la mobilisation maximale des moyens
de l'état comme comme cela a été
souligné
l'état a une responsabilité particulière
dans cette affaire d'abord parce que il
a laissé ce faire la liquidation
d'alstom en 2015 alors jeunes
n'échappe pas que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ji gaz
ce n'est pas la partie qui a été vendue
en 2015 bien en 1990 mais je veux
souligner une chose c'est qu'à partir du
moment où nous n'avons plus de groupes
industriels nationale dans le secteur
énergétique
depuis la vente d'alstom même toutes les
solutions de diversification qu'on va
promouvoir qu'on va défendre ensemble
parce que l'unité sur ce dossier et pour
le territoire de belfort et les
roumaines
elle sera là mais en tout état de cause
nous n'avons plus aujourd'hui de
véhicules d'entreprise de support pour
imaginer les diversifications ce qui va
rendre les solutions plus difficile
alors il ya eu si nous avions des
opérateurs il ya une piste cédric pin je
vous donnais la parole est une piste qui
a été abordé par le ministre par le
maire de belfort par les élus locaux
c'est l'aéronautique dont tout le monde
nous dit qu'elle est la plus prometteuse
à l'heure actuelle cédric perrin le
ministre a dit pour un euro investi dans
l'aéronautique part de general electric
à belfort je mettrais un euro d'argent
public en face comment
un site general electric à mettre de
l'argent sur bale sont dans
l'aéronautique c'est le principal
problème mois alors même jeu de general
electric je précise a déjà une
coentreprise avec ça avec simplement
c'est dans le cadre de cette
coentreprise avec safran que nous
militons pour que dans le cadre de la
fabrication du moteur leap qui explique
rappel je le rappelle équipe de nombreux
boeing et de nombreux rien vu qui est un
succès planétaire que la jv a beaucoup
de mal à fournir suffisamment de moteurs
ils recherchent des capacités de
production donc on est aujourd'hui en
discussion moi j'ai rencontré puisque je
connais très bien le pdg de safran
philippe petitcolin à paris avec damien
meslot florio bouclier de buka au mois
de janvier le 22 janvier près très
précisément qu'il s'est engagé lui a
donné 100 mille heures de travail à
belfort s'il j'y fais le même pas c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui il reste à
convaincre j les américains de rentrer
dans cette dans une organisation qui
nous permettent de faire ça à belfort
mais pour revenir sur ce que disait
bastien faut de tout à l'heure je pense
que le mot politique industrielle c'est
pas un gros mot et que aujourd'hui on se
souvient peut-être plus que après guerre
il ya eu le commissariat général au plan
il ya une vision stratégique de ce qu'on
voulait faire de la france et si
aujourd'hui on a des centrales
nucléaires si on à airbus si on allait
le tgv si on ariane si on a beaucoup de
choses c'est parce que sans doute à
abandonner le pouvoir politique s'est
emparé de ce sujet et a décidé un
certain nombre de choses et bien je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut revenir à
ça et vous savez j'ai déjà dit tout à
l'heure j'étais très heureux que bruno
le maire ait changé sa vision sur
l'avenir du gaz food raison simple c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on arrête
d'être dogmatiques et de dire aux
français qu' on ne veut plus de
nucléaire
on ne veut pas de gaz pas ce que c'est
des énergies fossiles
on ne veut que du photovoltaïque ou de
l'éolien sauf ce qu'on oublie de dire
aux gens c'est qu'on veut tous les faire
rouler en électrique et calendaires un
vrai problème
donc si personne ne voit le problème moi
je le vois assez facilement et le
dernier problème c'est que quand même
aujourd'hui la taxe intérieure sur les
produits pétroliers rapporte 50
milliards d'euros à la france 450
milliards d'euros à l'europe pour faire
une petite comparaison la politique
agricole commune au niveau européen
c'est 49 milliards donc comment on va
faire pour se priver de cette somme et
on va pas taxer l'électricité vous avez
déjà vu le cirque que vient de faire une
augmentation de 5 9%
donc une politique industrielle c'est
aussi une politique énergétique et c'est
une vision à long terme de ce qu'on veut
faire belfort est une est un centre
d'excellence mondial en matière
d'hydrogène en matière de recherche
fondamentale et je pense qu'elle est
sujet à creuser autour de l'aéronautique
de l'hydrogène et d'un certain nombre
d'autres points
effectivement il ya un problème de
temporalité je reviens toujours là
dessus c'est important denis sommer à
laquelle la question a été posée aux
ministres lundi quand il est venu à
belfort quels moyens de pression vous
avez sur de general electric pour les
convaincre il a dit l'éolien en mer
sauf que l'éolien en mer general
electric est en train de s'en désengager
pourquoi il se désengage de le lien le
maire a tué parce qu'il ya eu trop de
l'état a tellement tergiversé pour
donner une autorisation que de general
electric a décidé d'arrêter de ses
cahiers des recours oui mais attendez
abandonné on est le législateur capable
aussi de faire en sorte que dans ce pays
on arrête de créer des normes qui nous
empêchent d'avancer donc general
electric se retire de deux des trois
parcs éoliens où il devait fournir des
turbines et il lance une procédure de
rupture conventionnelle collectif pour
son site de nantes notamment et c'est
avec ces sur ce domaine là que le
gouvernement compte convaincre contre
mettre la pression sur general electric
va seul a du mal à comprendre mais pas
seulement vous imaginez bien y compris
que tout va peuple ne va pas forcément
être mise sur la table des négociations
y compris des négociations commerciales
ont fait du business pas seulement
d'ailleurs en france ni en europe avec
general electric des moyens de pression
il en existe moi je reviens sur la
question de la politique industrielle
c'est absolument inattendu les moyens de
pression tout le monde nous dit il en
existe mais comment on fait pour
convaincre une boîte privée pour que
narre l'on parle on crut main mais
comment on fait pour dire un dirigeant
d'entreprise
il faut que vous investissiez dans notre
site industriel où vous liquidez mille
emplois comment on fait quand on est élu
quand on est lui un il faut que
l'industriel à qui on parle
et une idée précise de ce que les
politiques veulent faire et donc pour
cela il faut une politique industrielle
je prends la question des énergies
renouvelables la question des éoliennes
l'essentiel des éoliennes connaissent
talent dans notre pays sont fabriqués où
elles sont fabriquées pour le mieux en
allemagne et on a besoin de fabriquer
des éoliennes chez nous il ya des
technologiques ont deux cons qu'on
domine parfaitement dans notre pays et
particulièrement à à belfort mais pour
cela il faut aussi que la france ait eu
une idée précise de ce qu'elle veut
développer dans le pays sur des
questions comme celle là la question de
l'hydrogène est absolument essentiel
l'hydrogène c'est l'énergie notamment de
l'avenir c'est l'énergie de l'avenir
grand pays comme la chine l'inde ou les
phénomène de métropolisation sont
extrêmement importants vont recours dans
les années qui viennent
énormément l'hydrogène comme vecteur
énergétique et comme moyen de stockage
inexistant le développement d'une
nouvelle industrie d'avancé pour se re
non de l'avant sur des sujets comme cela
et quand la démarche qui est engagée par
bruno le maire de dire mettez un euro la
france nous accompagnent les terres nous
accompagnons main euros et quand donc
donner de l'argent public susurre
rongeait sur des projets sur
l'aéronautique
ils agissaient sur l'aéronautique et sur
l'hydrogène sur d'autres mets donc
encore de l'argent public sur la table
pour l'allemande que par payer elle
supprime bilan mois que miles alliance
general electric ge et l'électrique
l'amande l'aéronautique l'objectif c'est
quoi ces deux quotidiens on met un euro
pour 1 euro c'est s'il ya une
capitalisation et le montage d'une
entreprise l'état est prêt à participer
à la capitalisation de l'entreprise pour
lancer une nouvelle production sur
belfort sous l'hydrogène c'est aussi la
possibilité qu'on a de diversifier le
tissu alors aujourd'hui on est au stade
de la recherche fondamentale de
l'application bientôt mais il faut quand
même savoir qu'à belfort personne ne
sait vraiment mais on a quand même le
centre de compétitivité véhicule du
futur avec la pole le pôle au fc lab qui
est quand même un des fleurons au niveau
mondial faute de clerc sur la recherche
fondamentale en la matière donc c'est
important je voudrais revenir sur ce que
vous dit tout à l'heure dans le circuit
tout à l'heure je discutais que syndicat
c'est à ce midi sur l'histoire de la de
la pression qu'on peut faire sur les
dirigeantes de jiff au sort
qu'aujourd'hui un dirigeant de crise aux
etats unis sont en suisse dans l'accord
qui a été signé en 2015 suite au rachat
de 2 power par parole par de wind power
par ji il était prévu que la direction
et le centre d'excellence soit a besoin
sera belfort à belfort et tout a été
déplacée en suisse quelque donc les uns
guère facilité on n'a donc pas été tués
c'était l'été en plus qu'elle et milan
peut faire aujourd'hui pour faire
respecter ses engagements à hadji c'est
une question mais comment on fait pour
exercer des pressions sur des gens qui
sont en suisse qui rapatrie en suisse
les bénéfices et qui exportent à belfort
les déficits il ya quand même un vrai
sujet autour de ça c'est la parole vous
n'avez pas la réponse et ben moi je n'ai
pas la réponse parce qu'aujourd'hui je
ne sais pas qui est capable dans
beaucoup de commentaires je donne la
parole monsieur lombard dont beaucoup de
commentaires qu'on nous envoie
reviens une question lancinante la
renationalisation frédéric pourquoi ne
pas re nationaliser les services de
l'énergie et d'autres services
stratégiques pour notre pays c'est vital
lounès le président de la république
directement responsable de ce gâchis
doit être sommé de protéger les salariés
et l'indépendance stratégique national
aujourd'hui le problème c'est que cette
activité elle appartient à une
entreprise américaine
donc ils ans est fini il n'y aura plus
privé on peut pas nationalisées on n'est
pas dans un état totalitaire donc la
seule manière de récupérer ces de
racheter on voit quelqu'un qui veut pas
ouvrir elle vous racheter un prix fou et
toute façon s'il veut pas vous le vendre
ils ne vous le vendra pas donc pour
l'instant le problème avant le crash
c'est d'éviter le rocher donc dans les
villes en rocher c'était de mettre la
bonne personne au sommet pour l'instant
nous avons mâcon qui lui traite et avant
tout nos perles à l'étranger et puis
quelques-uns aussi aux aux européens
donc la solution immédiate fin immédiate
il y en a malheureusement pas immédiate
parce que peut-être que dans trois mois
on va voir des gens qui seront au
chômage avec ce que ça correspond je
pense que tout le monde ici on est on
est bien au courant avec les familles
les les enfants les scolarités tout ça
c'est un problème énorme et la réponse
malheureusement politique immédiatement
pour moi c'est triste à dire mais elle
n'existe pas il fallait changer de cap
avant il fallait pas laisser faire
monsieur mâcon qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire effectivement au niveau du gaz au
niveau du gaz je ne pense pas qu enfin
j'ai des informations qui certifie que
au niveau du gaz on a des possibilités
des possibilités qui sont au lieu de
prendre des d'avoir investi sur les les
comment tout tout les niveaux électrique
au niveau en photovoltaïque ou en éolien
ce sont des trucs temporaire la nuit on
n'y a pas de lumière et le vent est tout
à fait temporaire en plus comme le
disait monsieur si les turbines à gaz
permet les sur des notabilités
absolument avec très peu de pollution
d'avoir une rentabilité bien meilleure
de l'ordre de 75% alors qu'une éolienne
c'est 25% si on met tout dedans quand
elles quand elles marchent plus à côté
le secteur où on peut re balance est
effectivement au niveau rire au nautic
puis ctcc mon j'ai volé plusieurs fois
avec des de general electric
mais sur le comment sur le côté atomique
à la côte et l'autre branche
si on repousse un petit peu cette loi de
transition et de
comme en écho logique qu'on a signé la
lt cv qui met une butée de 50% de moins
en comment nucléaire en deux en 2025 si
on repousse 7 buts et on peut réinvestir
on peut rénover nos centrales atomiques
les prolonger un peu plus longtemps en
attendant de trouver un palliatif en
attendant parce que le bien-être le
bien-être de tout le monde ça commence
tout simplement par manger
tranquillement à la maison
et puis l'écologie c'est un fait de
certains mais on commence par être bien
chez soi avant de bastien faudrait sûr
que vous avez d'accord avec un patrice
lombard il n'y a pas de solution de
réponses politiques à court terme mais à
court terme il faut s'occuper des
salariés de leur classement et leur
trouver un boulot faire comment la
mention millimes amis dans un premier
temps faire la pression maximale sur
general electric dont je souligne que
nous sommes clients
nous avons donc quand même des capacités
d'action sur eux elles seront plus
limités c'est à dire en menaces sur les
appels d'offres par exemple bon tout de
suite les grands mots les menaces à la
vie on leur explique nous avons des
intérêts que eux en ont et qu'il faut
qu'on trouve ces gens d'affaires
québécois et c'est que des fois je
rappelle quand même qu'ils ont dix sept
mille salariés en france et qu'il a il
ennuie 106 milles et que le bras de fer
avec dur électrique c'est aussi 17 15
mille emplois qui restreint et le
ministre a très clairement rappelé lors
de la réunion qu'on a eu lundi faire
pression sur la dgi d'accord enfin bon
il faut quand même se veut se prendre en
considération le fait qu'il représente
17 mille emplois dans ce pays
donc faut y aller doucement quand même
c'est pas moi qui ai dit je vois là
sinon on fonctionne toujours quelque
part avec le trouillomètre mais parce
que nos responsables politiques
t c'est la philosophie même du
libéraliste r on pense que le marché est
au dessus de tous que les chefs
d'entreprises y compris les grands
groupes sont au dessus de nos chefs
d'état et c'est cette culture là qui a
fini par convaincre la plupart de nos
élites économiques médiatiques
financière c'est évident alors le savez
celle qui l'a dit dans la presse cette
semaine son je sais pas on dit noir le
regard chevènement un ancien ne me
surprend pas complètement le drame
auquel tu aurais tu un drame national
celui de l'abandon de nos
industrie de l'ain videmment ça se parle
nos élites financiarisé bons coups mais
voilà donc de fait il y a sur ce plan là
d'abord une pression exercée sur general
electric pour maintenir l'activité
défendre la turbine à gaz à belfort
ensuite une fois qu'on aura exercer
cette pression
tous les emplois qu'on n'aura pas pu
maintenir si toutefois nous n'arrivons
pas à les convaincre de maintenir
l'activité
c'est là où il ya un travail phénoménal
a engagé de diversification ma position
est qu'il sera difficile de l'envisager
uniquement avec des outils de bricolage
quoi en fait c'est à dire que il faut
qu'il y ait une volonté politique forte
au sommet de l'état pour dire ça va pas
se faire d'ici demain matin on
reconstruit un groupe industriel
national quitte à ce que la puissance
publique met de l'argent dans la sphère
et vous là on ne je veux avoir un
mot là-dessus monsieur chevreuil on ne
te bats en 2019 prétendre être une
grande nation dans le monde être une
grande nation en europe
si nous abandonne si nous abandonnons
toute ambition de détenir un groupe
industriel sur les questions
énergétiques l'énergie notre
indépendance a donné ses instructions
énergétique est fondamental et je dirais
pour le site de belfort en termes de
diversification
c'est au regard des enjeux
extraordinaires qui sont devant nous en
termes d'innovation de recherche de
diversification des sources d'énergie et
notamment des énergies renouvelables il
y à un chantier à engager petit bayal
est timidement je finis là dessus ça
veut dire qu'il faut que l'état
investisse aussi massivement dans le
plan qu'il proposera pour le nord
franche comté dans l'université la
recherche denis sommer le représentant
de la majorité que vous êtes vous êtes
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
bastien photos sur l'île et qui font une
grande politique industrielle en matière
de en matière d'énergie oui bien
évidemment que je suis d'accord et mais
pour cela il faut encore une fois il
faut savoir exactement ce que l'on veut
faire et quelles sont les priorités
laissez vous que ça au pouvoir
aujourd'hui donc qu'est-ce qu'on verrait
ça me trouve bien agressif non non non
mais bien quelque part c'est un peu
désagréable
voilà je vous le dis bien oui non je
vous le dis je vous le dis donc il
définir une politique industrielle
j'ai essayé c'est ce que j'ai tenté de
dire tout à l'heure par rapport à
l'éolien
il ya des vrais enjeux dans ce dans ce
domaine là par rapport à l'hydrogène moi
je crois beaucoup à cette technique là
parce que pourquoi pas tout simplement
parce que c'est ça nous permet de
stocker de l'énergie
ça nous permet de les redistribuer et
c'est un complément indispensable aux
énergies renouvelables celles
indispensables
et puis il ya un sujet il faut garder
nos compétences parce qu'une politique
industrielle elle se conduit à partir du
moment où il ya des compétences
scientifiques sera préservé il faut les
préserver nous avions mis en place
en revanche comptait former plutôt que
chômer obligé de vous arrêter c'est la
fin de l'émission est plutôt que chômer
je pense qu'il faut il faut retravailler
ses rides à tous d'avoir suivi cette
émission bas d'après midi